[Music]
I've lived a life guided by completely
by desire in the sense that my guiding
principle as an artist has always been
to try to make the music that I most
wanted to hear so in listening to music
or looking at art I'm always thinking
two things I'm always thinking that's
great but actually it could be a bit
better if they had done this or that or
the other and a lot of the work that
I've made has come from the desire to
see something in existence that didn't
already exist it's it's never come
actually from the desire to make money
or to be famous though of the to the
latter is the more forgivable and I
think so I started to think what what is
desire for why have we evolved to have
desires because in fact we clearly do
respond to two types of signals one of
them is pain and pain tells us what to
avoid
but desire I think tells us what to go
for what to navigate towards now we like
sweetness for instance we we eat sweet
things why do we like sweet things we
like sweet things because sweetness is a
signal that something is at its maximum
vitamin value it's the right time for us
to eat it we like in my case attractive
women why do we do that because that
signal is saying that person is fertile
and you could multiply yourself with
that person
so romantic yes so so I'm thinking
desire is the is the sort of eudaimonic
reward it's the it's the thing that says
this is the right thing to be doing
so what interests me is what happens
when we virtualize our desires for
instance when I want sweetness now I
don't go and pick a cherry or an apple I
go and buy a Twix bar or something like
that what a Twix bar is it's the
sweetness without the benefits of the
sweetness it's the sweetness without the
vitamins that go with it we evolved that
desire for sweetness because it was a
way of improving ourselves essentially
physically improving ourselves so we can
now have sweetness without physically
improving ourselves in fact with making
ourselves quite a lot fatter we can now
have sex of a certain kind without
procreating so the thing that sex
evolved for has now been virtualized
into pornography or not necessarily
pornography heavy petting could be as
well essentially virtualization removes
us from the consequences of our
appetites and of course we now are a
newer stage of virtualization where we
have no virtue alized certain things
that used to be unvirtuous able such as
friendship we virtualized friendship by
having Facebook and Instagram and so on
we've we've managed to virtualize
activity we we were born with the need
to move around and with muscles that
want to stretch and so on and most of us
can't do that much of that so we go to
gyms or play football or whatever but
now we don't even do that we play
playstation so we have virtualized
activity we're running around but we're
not actually moving from our seat so
this is a new phase of human affairs I
think when and I think this it's
actually the answer to Fermi's paradox
do you know what Fermi's paradox is
Fermi's paradox is that if there are so
many stars in the universe and therefore
possibly so many habitable planets
and the number seems to go up every by a
power of 10 every few months why are we
not aware of any other civilizations why
does it just seem to be us and Geoffrey
West I think it was answered well of
course when we reach the stage when we
where we can virtualize all our
pleasures we stop trying to do anything
else outside in the world we can afford
to do everything inside the confines of
the box the TV set the computer so you
know most of the things that manifest
the existence of a civilization are the
result of that civilization trying to
broadcast something normally to its
other members but incidentally those
broadcasts would be heard elsewhere well
in a sense we've stopped broadcasting I
think and that to me is the sign that
we're at the end of the cycle I think
there may have been many many many other
civilizations that like us are being
killed by their own desire or have been
killed by them and on that cheerful note
my sister
[Applause]
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas